todo estaba destruido todo absolutamente
todo la puerta las ventanas todo hasta
hace nueve meses la casa de alí estaba
en el centro de los combates la última
guerra civil asoló las afueras del sur
de trípoli saltar es un criminal lamento
decirlo un gran criminal una guerra
iniciada en 2019 por califa haftar
hombre del esté dispuesto a todo por
tomar el control del país doscientos mil
libios se vieron obligados a huir la
casa de alí fue ocupada por hombres del
este durante casi un año los grafitis
sobre los muros lo demuestran
en todos los barrios situados a las
afueras en el sur de trípoli los
combatientes vandalizaron las casas y
cavaron túneles para ganar posiciones
salían por ahí mire partieron aquí
cuando combatían era por ahí
las tropas fieles a cali qatar fueron
expulsadas de la capital en junio pasado
son acusadas de haber intervenido las
casas mientras subían había una mina
aquí también
y nos pidieron que no volviéramos
directamente a nuestras casas porque
tenían miedo de las minas y de las
bombas muchas personas murieron
esta guerra fue demasiado para él y sin
embargo este profesor de misrata apoyó a
la revolución de 2011 que sacó del poder
a muamar gadafi tras 42 años de régimen
autoritario no digo que gadafi habría
tenido que quedarse en el poder no
porque hizo muchas cosas malas en el
país es por culpa suya que las personas
no están educadas
pero de todas maneras extraño algo de su
época la paz y la seguridad
y hoy en día ni siquiera es posible
recorrer una distancia corta
esa es la diferencia la paz y la
seguridad que teníamos bajo gadafi
ese sentimiento de nostalgia se ha
apoderado de muchos libros
la euforia post gadafi dio paso a un
ciclo de violencia
una sucesión de tres guerras fratricidas
que oponían milicias excesivamente
armadas y dejaban un país entero de este
a oeste exhausto
entre el fuego cruzado se acumularon los
tormentos cotidianos para 7 millones de
libios venimos de un barrio en las
afueras de trípoli allá no hay gasolina
debemos venir hasta trípoli para poner
gasolina llenas de harina
esperamos que la vida mejor en libia que
sea estable que nos deshagamos de las
milicias con un gobierno unido y con una
libia unida a los grupos armados
utilizan los bloqueos de las áreas
petroleras como un medio de presión es
el país más rico en petróleo del
continente africano se volvió
dependiente de las importaciones así es
todos los días todos los días
es para los generadores hay cortes de
electricidad durante ocho horas al día
así es desde la revolución
antes no había corte
desde hace 10 años es el mismo problema
no hay solución cada vez que hay un
nuevo gobierno pasan 23 años pero los
problemas no se solucionan
y es el ciudadano el que sufre
por todas partes en trípoli se ve en
estas largas filas de espera en las
estaciones de gasolina esta es una de
las imágenes visibles de las
dificultades diarias que padecen los
libios desde la revolución de 2011 se
han agravado con el paso de los años a
causa de la inseguridad y de la
inestabilidad política
otra imagen estas mujeres y hombres de
pie delante de los bancos para retirar
su salario la causa una crisis de
liquidez de vida dos bancos centrales
competidores en el este dinero este un
mercado negro inestable y una constante
escasez de dinero al ser imágenes
consideradas demasiado sensibles para
las autoridades debemos grabar con
discreción constantemente se le ponen
trabas a nuestro trabajo
no obstante las dificultades económicas
no podrán ser disimuladas durante mucho
tiempo la pobreza invade la población
está caro la vida se volvió cara hacemos
nuestras compras y nada más apenas
logramos hacer nuestras compras es duro
es duro
antes había una variedad de productos
carnes medicamentos teníamos de todo
todo eso estaba respaldado por el estado
aquel tiempo en el que moamar gadafi se
distribuía las ganancias de las rentas
petroleras para comprar la paz pertenece
al pasado
en 2020 el precio de los productos de
primera necesidad subió más de 50 por
ciento
mohamed abastece tres puestos en el
mercado más grande de trípoli
la mayoría de los productos provienen de
egipto
hay problemas con los productos que
vienen del este es por la ruta costera
durante la guerra pusieron minas y el
eje principal sigue cerrado entonces no
sabemos cómo hacer para que lleguen los
productos sin que se pudran nuestros
sueños como ciudadanos son sencillos
ofrezcamos un salario un hospital un
colegio transportes todo es muy sencillo
son derechos elementales
sueños que podrían tardar todavía años
en hacerse realidad incluso aunque los
recientes cambios políticos y la
perspectiva de las elecciones en
diciembre del pazo para la emergencia de
un optimismo muy prudente
estos últimos 10 años han sido sinónimo
de guerras sufrimiento y muchas
frustraciones para la población con el
nombramiento del nuevo poder ejecutivo
los libaneses esperan por cien la
reconciliación nacionales y las mejoras
concretas de su calidad de vida